[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huge moments of surprise
that leave you wrecked
the Wreckers
on the old black Cornish rocks when
there was no moonlight
and hard storms pushed the waves and
winds to treachery would light their
lamps to lure the ships ashore
and ships who thought that they were
safe and lights were there to guide them
home would run aground
All Hands lost and stolen by the cold
sea
foreign
[Music]
to share the good times
is to share the bad times
to share the joy in the fine wine times
is to drink the wine down to the bottom
of the glass
where things are bitter
I will not ask for any glass to pass
from me
there are no accidents
or possibly there are
but things happen because of their
nature
and there is no arguing with nature but
she is wise and innocent and cruel and
rage and hurt and pain and blood
a hearse
[Music]
foreign
so we build
rituals of mourning and acceptance
to walk us through the nights of Tears
pain
but nature lost a daughter
who remains six seeds of pomegranate
dead today
[Music]
three things I send you
first I send these words
that you may use them as a pool of ink
to see yourself reflected or see another
in to see far away things
so you do not forget to dream
and then I send you pain
the small pain to whisper to your pain
and keep it company
and last
they send a smile
that it might serve you well
you may hold it in a time when
Smiles are scarce
[Music]
remembering the moonlight
on the water